wo ist dein leben
[Musik]
ich habe mein auto verkauft sich gut
du kannst meine nikos bewerbung für die
schauspielschule lesen willst jetzt noch
versuchen was wo zu darstellen wozu du
bist gut
es ist wichtig dass alles korrekt ist
also name adresse telefonnummer
geburtsdatum geburtsort nationalität
spanier soweit in ordnung
schulausbildung ist hier
sprachkenntnisse computerkenntnisse ok
interessen und fähigkeiten
seit wann und wo siehst du dich denn für
modernes theater das hast du selbst
geschrieben ja also der lebenslauf ist
bis auf ein paar kleine
rechtschreibfehler so schon in ordnung
ich will vorschlagen wir schauen uns mal
deinen motivationsschreiben an
also hier können wir auf jeden fall noch
ein paar formulierungen ändern
ein motivationsschreiben muss
überzeugender sein macht es persönlich
warum jetzt auf diese schule und warum
bist du der richtige dafür
du interessierst dich doch für das
studium oder klar
danke dass morgen also später
da ist noch was hier die struktur einer
website
ich habe ein paar kurze texte
geschrieben und ist nur ein erster
entwurf aber ich schaue einfach mal rein
fertig machen
danke
das später ja
[Musik]